So, what's an example of a data visualization, that tells a subjective story,
rather than an objective one.
>> Sure, a popularly sited one is actually one that we have up here
which is one that Steve Jobs showed, and it's a 3D pie chart, and
It's confusing really when you kind of just look at it.
Because, as you can see here, so the 19.5% represented by the green part of
the pie, visually if you didn't have those cues of the annotations.
It looks to the eye almost the same size as the 39% here, and
definitely larger than the 21.2%.
And so it's just really confusing because pie charts can be a little confusing,
especially in this way if it's 3D.
Because it doesn't let the eye effectively take in the data.
So it can be pretty confusing and
let folks use graphs in a way that might be misleading or confusing.
Especially if you aren't able to understand what the data behind it is.